all right guys
bang bang i've got eric here thank you
so much for doing this sir
yeah happy to be here thanks for having
me for sure we're gonna try to make this
one of the most
action-packed actionable and
information-filled episodes that we've
done eric
is a wealth of knowledge so let's get
into it maybe let's just start with your
background
uh and kind of what you've done up until
today yeah sure so i'll try to keep it
brief um so name is
eric sue and i mainly kind of hover in
the marketing world so i got a podcast
called marketing school another one
called leveling up
um and then there have a couple
businesses one's a ad agency
and then one is a software company
called clickflow have operators running
those businesses
and then other than that i just um you
know got a book coming out called
leveling up i just tried to try to play
the game of life and honestly like you
know
used to come from esports background i
was just like man like i just need to
find something where i feel like i'm
playing a game everything honestly it's
just like it's just
business and like creating stuff so um
yeah that's my background
i love it that's a great way to live
life uh as i was thinking through what
could we possibly talk about because
there's so much stuff
i ultimately settled on uh you've shared
a million ideas publicly and i figured i
would just throw them out there at you
uh and we can kind of riff on them um
the first one i want to go through
is seo uh you have created probably more
content than almost anyone i know on
this topic
um and you have a recent tweet thread
that says over one million blog posts
are published daily
google is shrinking organic results seo
is harder but that's fine because you're
strong
here are a few creative things you can
do to drive your organic traffic up
and the first kind of suggestion is to
buy
other websites talk through why that's
such a good idea
yeah so maybe maybe i'll i'll rewind
real quick just to just
give paid the some context for people
around seo so i think you know a lot of
people right now especially in tech
um you know they do demand generation
and all that and it's like demand
generation just running facebook ads or
google ads and like there's actually a
lot more than that
when it comes to marketing and so i
think seo is one of the most unfair
advantages you can establish
um because what happens is if you have a
lot of traffic come to your website
let's say a hundred thousand or so
you can retarget those people later um
you follow them around with those ads
you can um you can do a lot more right
and then you can plug in you know other
stuff like customer data platforms email
like all these tools
you know that you have access to and you
don't have to keep you know paying these
big app platforms and you know you're
kind of at their
their their whim right they decide to
ban you they ban you so
anyway um seo you know the two most
important things still to this day are
content and links right you still have
to have a lot of great content a lot of
links
and some people that you know they make
so much money um some of my buddies they
make so much money they don't know what
to do they don't want to pay taxes on it
so they just deploy the money
back into content and links and they
just make even more money right uh
that's the game of seo you just keep
compounding it's
just like investing in stocks is just
like putting money into
crypto it's the same deal so um
when i talk about buying websites the
problem with seo
is that it takes too long people aren't
patient right it's like 18 to 24 a month
probably 36 months journey to start to
see some good stuff happen
when i took over my company um single
writing the ad agency
um we were doing uh maybe 4 000 visits a
month which was nothing
now you know we're up to 320 000 which
is pretty decent for a marketing website
but we took those tactics and i started
another blog with a friend we went from
zero to four million visits a month
right
and so it's the same stuff and so um but
instead of waiting zero to 36 months or
so or 36
months we'll just call it that go and
look at other websites that have
a good um in seo it's called a domain
authority
so you know you're scored on scale of
one to one hundred zero to one hundred
um you wanna buy a site with you know
maybe 80 plus domain authority and
ideally you might you could check out
some of these uh
these brokerage websites like flippa.com
or fe international
um there's a lot of these brokerage
websites and you can see you know what
i don't want to wait i'm just going to
go buy a website and um you know when i
buy the website i'm just gonna go
you know create a bunch of new content
it's gonna rank and then i'm gonna be
making a boatload more money and i can
use this website
as an acquisition system um that will
pay me in perpetuity and get me more
leads instead of saying
i just got to go to linkedin facebook or
google and try to buy more leads
what do you see people monetizing with
right so they go and they buy a website
they've already got great domain
authority is this their monetizing
through ads on the website they're
selling products a mixture
how do you see that working yeah you're
looking to um you're looking to
arbitrage here right because you're
looking for websites that have good
traffic
that um that are that are not monetizing
the right way in my opinion like if you
have a lot of traffic and you're just
monetizing off of ads
you're probably not thinking it through
and you're probably just bored of the
website
so what i would do is i would reach out
to these people and ask if they're
interested in partnering up right
so you might hit them up on linkedin you
might go you know find their email
addresses
um you know you'll find their contact
information and then just hit up a bunch
of them and say
you know a certain person are going to
respond to you and you and then
instead of saying i'm going to invest in
your company people get kind of like you
know they don't
really want to talk to you if you say
that but i'm going to invest different
story or
sorry i want to partner with you
different story and that's how you get
the conversation going got it
another uh suggestion in this thread was
to monitor your decaying
content and then update it explain that
yeah
so what tends to happen over time is if
you don't tend to your garden
right things start to get unruly right
you know that the kale starts to go
everywhere the carrots and i don't have
a garden i'm just making things up
but um you know the point is content
tends to decay over time if you're not
upgrading it so
one example of this is uh wikipedia
so wikipedia they had this uh
page on abraham lincoln over the years
like it first started out with
five thousand words there was eight
thousand words and now it's like you
know fifteen thousand or twenty thousand
words or so
point is people are constantly updating
the content over time and google
likes freshness right you know we just
use google what's the main search engine
um but also like if you take a look at
yelp or you take a look at tripadvisor
you have
a lot of ugc user generated content
they're constantly you know
updating it for the website that's how
they get stronger and stronger it just
kind of defends their
their kind of organic search mode um
so what you could do is you can use
whatever
analytics tool platform you have and
just look at your top posts over time
and see if they're losing traffic right
um we actually have a tool that's out
there for free um
if you just google click flow content
decay it's totally free and it'll
actually monitor like when you're losing
like
you know 20 80 of your traffic the whole
idea here is that
if you have like a top 10 or top 20 list
of posts because 80 20 rule the top 20
would drive to 80 percent of traffic
um you don't want to lose that traffic
so what you're doing ideally
is maybe you're adding you know maybe a
paragraph or b even more content
to these um you know every couple months
and you're tending to your garden
people just like create content the
problem right now with seo is like
created you know million plus blog posts
a day and we're just gonna leave it
right it's like you don't buy a car
and then you know you drive it for two
weeks and you're done right it's just
like you wanna make the most of it
absolutely
the next suggestion is to test titles
tags
meta descriptions to drive a higher
click through yep
so you know when you think about um
those of you that run ads or like you're
testing email subject lines you're
when you're running ads right you're
testing like on google for example
your your a b testing titles and a
description
um or if you're testing you know email
subject lines you want to see which one
gets a higher open rate right
so same deal when it comes to to seo
what you want to think about is
you know if i have a title um you know
marketing blog versus like best
marketing blog you know
updated for 2020 and beyond or whatever
um the second one is probably gonna get
a higher click-through rate and so what
you want to be doing is you know you can
use a tool like google search console
which is completely free
and then you look at your content that
has a uh this is getting a little into
the weeds but
hot you know it has a high impression
count but a low click the rate so
you know google's showing your post a
lot but you as a marketer or whoever you
are the site owner
you're not doing a good job from a
marketing perspective because
marketing's job is to bring people to
the point of sale
to get people to click right so it's the
same deal like if you're doing title
testing for ads or emails like why
aren't you doing it for seo if you're
getting good traffic
um and so same deal with clickflow we
created a solution to make it easier i'm
not here to pump that i mean just
you know google search console you can
do it completely for free so absolutely
what about using frequently asked
questions that schema
as a way to a better rank yeah so
there's actually um
so what's happening right now with
google is um
you know they're they have to please
their shareholders right so they
actually remove that whole you know
don't be evil thing
um so they're making you know they're
making the ads look like search results
and um you know they're making on
certain search engine result pages like
it's hard to see the organic results
period there's like all these snippets
and stuff
so um what you want to be doing um
when it comes to faq schema so faq
scheme is like
you know if i type in um you know uh
anthony pompliano or you know
i don't know um wardrobe or something
like that right so
um people might have an faq like you
know what well what is you know what
does pomp put in his hair or whatever
right there's like a bunch of other
questions
so that pops up as a box and that box
imagine if you're seeing a box on a
search engine result page
you're hire you're you're gonna be more
likely to click that because it's taking
up so much real estate
so if you want to implement faq schema
talk to your web developer i would just
type in faq schema plugin
for whatever you know cms or content
management system that you're using
and then boom you have faq schema for
your website you're gonna get a higher
click-through rate hopefully
um and there's a lot of different ways
to do it but i would just hand it off to
you know whoever your
your developer your engineer is and then
if you have a wordpress site there's a
lot of wordpress plugins for it
absolutely so switching gears you had
this tweet about uh don't ask people for
coffee or to pick their brain until
you've deposited
in the relationship bank and i found
that uh concept of a relationship bank
really interesting explain that
yeah so i think i mean and i've done
this in the past i mean i'm sure you
know um you have a lot of people that
reach out to you asking you to just get
coffee or talk to you for five to ten
minutes
and you know i actually put this on
linkedin too like i i kind of
exaggerated i was like it's downright
offensive right um because you wanna you
know stir people up a little bit but
um i found what what's worked best for
me because like instead of asking people
you know i'm gonna pay five dollars for
like your most valuable asset your time
that that's not an equal trade-off right
but if i am looking at your tweets for
example looking at what you're
interested in
and i offer to help you maybe i'm making
you're like oh i'm looking to hire some
engineers or whatever it's like hey
here are three engineers that i know i
happen to have a recruiting agency
boom i've actually helped you i've
looked at your stuff that's a little bit
that's that's saying something and i've
actually gone out and done the work i'm
not making you think about anything
and i'm just gonna you know the concept
of i'm gonna make little deposits every
day
maybe i want to get on your radar
whatever it is exactly um
and then at some point i'm gonna make a
withdrawal right i'm not gonna make a
big withdrawal but my whole thing is
like i i just like you know
making more deposits more than anything
so i have a margin of safety so when i
make an ask it's like not that big of a
thing
um and i'll give you some examples i
mean
there's two people i'm thinking of right
now one guy actually works for
vaynermedia now
what he wanted to work for me he wrote
an 8 000 word blog post right guy went
to
michigan and he was like yeah here's
what i would do here's what i'll do
here's what i do and i'll tell you what
i'll do it for you for free for a month
right and i'm just like dude this guy
gets me and you know guy turns out to be
an all-star and then he's working for
for vaynermedia now um and another guy
he um he's like hey look i follow your
podcast i'm gonna i'll write some emails
for you
to help you get more conversions and
i'll do it for you completely for free
for a month
like not only are you not only have you
looked at my stuff
you've volunt you you put together a
strategy and then you think you'll do
the work and then you said you do it for
free for a month
and you have no ask like that's the
dream so that's way better than like
asking for coffee especially if you're
like
trying to ask warren buffett for his
time right which you probably won't get
so
absolutely another idea is this idea of
you don't actually have to talk to the
end
customer in order to get the customer
insights in every situation sometimes
you do have to talk to him but other
times you don't what are some of the
hacks there
yeah so i did um this is i did two
podcast episodes one was with um
the levels ceo um sam corkos and
what was fascinating to me was when i
opted into so it's like a
patch you use to kind of monitor your
metabolic state but um
he he was like hey let's get on a
45-minute call i was like oh damn this
guy's doing customer development
and when i when i got on the call with
him i was like hey tell me like how many
calls have you done he's like over a
thousand i was like holy crap
right i was like i would i don't think i
could ever do that that's that's a lot
of patience right and
that's like you know that's great but
anyway i can't do it so
i talked to the ceo of a superhuman raul
and he was like look man like i met up
with like maybe 30 people 40 people or
so in san francisco we had coffee
whatever
um and then there's the coffee thing and
then um
i guess it's equal trade but then he was
like you know what um i just made a
simple landing page
um using like wix and then you know
whoever wanted to sign up for the tool
could sign up but then right after they
signed up they would ask them
um hey like you know what's your what's
the worst like your biggest frustration
with email like what would you like to
see right
and then he'll get a ton of responses
and he just cherry pick the ones he
likes
and so he was basically doing customer
development at scale because
he was getting automated responses he's
cherry picking but he was just
responding really quick to people
and that helped guide his customer
development so there's two ways to do it
you can do it the
i i love what sam corkos did with levels
and then i would actually prefer
roles because i'm lazy so absolutely
well and this feeds into the next idea
which is basically
kind of like creating the ideal client
profile right so whether it's
more of like a retail consumer or it's a
agency based client
um it feels like knowing who you want to
work with
is almost as important as knowing who
you don't want to work with yeah
yeah i mean there's there's actually a
lot of good ideal client
profile templates out there but i mean
so for our sas
company as an example we might have
people that are um
you know you have people that are
mid-market companies you have enterprise
and then we try to stay away from small
business but
you know maybe for mid-market they're
doing maybe 10 million annual recurring
revenue
enterprise you know probably let's just
say you know hundreds of millions or
billions plus
and then they have very specific things
they're looking for maybe
enterprise levels you know maybe they're
looking for business intelligence more
so than like
you know um different features for for
the mid-market right so i'm just saying
that you really have to understand kind
of who you're going after
um and actually here's the thing i
literally just got off a podcast with uh
justin khan from twitch
and i asked him about his failures and
here's what he said um so twitch sold to
amazon for a billion dollars um
great exit so he was like you know the
common thing with
all my my failures was that um
i didn't do enough um
i didn't do enough customer development
i didn't try to focus on one
segment i tried to do maybe two three
two like that's too many segments right
and that led to you know trying to go
all over the place and serve everyone so
if you're starting out focus on one and
then if you're gonna
um you know at a certain point you know
you're doing this for six to 12 months
you'll understand
who your ideal client profile is i think
what we did as an agency a couple years
ago was helpful because
we looked at you know the the lifetime
value of each customer and then we just
saw that like
oh it turns out that we serve sas
companies the best they stay the longest
and they pay the most
and they're like not a pain in the ass
so we decided to focus on being
a sas marketing agency um versus
everything else which is kind of all
over the place on the map
it also creates this level of like uh i
want to be in the exclusive club i want
to be accepted into uh your customer
base right which is like a weird uh
dynamic but it definitely creates this
uh this fomo feeling a little bit
yeah you i mean you got the power i mean
it's um i think you're creating the
right incentives because it's like
people want people that
that specialize you don't want to go you
want to go to like an orthopedic surgeon
for like you know
very specific things or like uh like an
eye doctor right you want to go to like
a general doctor so
for sure uh you mentioned a couple of
really great entrepreneurs
and one of the things that almost every
entrepreneur has that uh is successful
is an advisory board i've seen you talk
quite a bit about the importance of
a really strong successful advisory
board how do you think about that
yeah so i think earlier in my career
like i would read a lot of books and
then people be talking about you know
peer groups and advisory boards so
one thing i did i'm trying to make this
practical for everyone um
if you google mastermind talks um
dinner pdf you'll be able to find a pdf
and what i did was i gathered
like-minded marketers because i didn't
have a business at the time
um and you know i had to have them come
over to my place i'd buy dinner
and then um you know we put people in
the hot seat i put together like an
agenda and everything so
people talk about the latest marketing
tactics and strategies
hot seat one thing they're struggling
with and we all kind of just help each
other right you have a little mini
community there
and then as you level up through your
career then
um you know as you get stronger then i
would say you know there's a lot of
different peer groups right
there's entrepreneurs organization
there's ypo
and part of both i love both of those
and you get you get to basically have
like a
a mini board of directors right so i
remember when i first joined uh eo
uh entrepreneurs organization i was you
know 27 at the time everyone else was
like 35 plus and they had way more
experience than i did
and what you realize is that you don't
know what you don't know right
and so this group what they do is um
they'll like one guy shared
like his cash flow uh forecast with me
like 10 weeks i was like what what is
what is that right
and then um you know they're just what
happens is i'll share a struggle
and then everyone else will share an
experience they won't give direct advice
and that to me is a little advisory
board there because i'm kind of
i'll know what to do next based on what
i think i should do i'm not taking any
advice
um so that's one example of advisory
boards and obviously i think you know
when it comes to um you know i right now
i'm on a couple advisory boards for like
some some
some companies out there and you know in
some cases they're just asking me for
advice maybe once a month like we'll get
on the call for like an hour
um in other cases i might be a little
more involved um but that's another
example you might
you know give a person maybe like you
know half a percent one percent two
percent equity
and um you know you're on their advisory
board or you you have them join yours
absolutely uh now the reason why
everyone is obviously listening to this
is the next question which is uh how to
become famous on instagram
everyone wants to be famous on instagram
uh i saw that you guys did a
podcast episode on this that was uh
really really interesting based on kind
of all the different hacks and and tips
uh maybe walk us through kind of how you
guys think about that strategy
yeah so this is um you know we have a
podcast called markings go and do it
with another marketer named neil patel
um to be fair um my instagram isn't
super huge it's like 24k he's at like a
200k or so
so neither of us are instagram famous
but we know a lot of people that are and
we know what they do
um so you know the one thing that we
found to work really well is just
siphoning off of someone else's audience
um so it's like if if
i am let's say i'm at 24k what i would
do is i might reach out to someone
that's at 50k or 75
or 100k i don't want to go too big
because it's too far
up right i like ideally what what you
might want to do is you know if you're
at 24k but you have some other assets
that you think might be able to help
that person again you want to make it an
equal trade
so i might say hey look i have 24k here
but i might have a podcast over here
that's the angle
and then um you know let's go ahead and
do a live on instagram
and boom all the people coming that
scene the live now they know they now
know you by association
and you get bigger faster um giveaways
always work well i think
they're you're going to get a lot of
spam and a lot of kind of people that
are just there to be tire kickers though
um but you can use a tool like king sumo
giveaways for that
um but we haven't been super big on
trying to grow our ig fast just because
it's not
you know both of us we serve kind of b2b
audiences so you know
we'll let it grow organically and then
see where it goes but you know if you do
have other assets
um like an email list that is like an
unfair advantage so
you know leverage that when you can
especially for growing a podcast by the
way if you have an email list dude
unbeatable
absolutely and one of the things you do
in emails obviously is you write copy
i've seen you talk about maybe more
landing page copy but it applies to
emails as well
most people write copy trying to be
interesting or trying to kind of catch
people's attention
uh kind of click bait right is the is
the terminology
uh yeah you're much more focused on
writing copy that
uh highlights you can solve somebody's
prop
right what's the nuance or what's the
difference there yeah i think
for me i just realized that um you know
whenever i try to sound interesting i
end up sounding an idiot
uh so so what i try to do instead is i
just try to be helpful like that's the
only thing that's been
that's the one thing that's been super
helpful to me throughout the years it's
just
um you know if someone needs something
i'll be out there like if i find an
interesting insight i'm gonna try to
share it with people
um and like i'll always ask people like
you know what do you need exactly what's
the number one thing right
and i've naturally like that wasn't
natural to me but i've learned to make
it more of a natural habit
so um when i think about like oh like
what's something i can um
what's something of value i can post out
there um
that lens is a lot more helpful than hey
i want to create some content and i want
to be famous i think chasing status
more so than trying to be helpful is not
the best game
so absolutely and i guess when you're
writing that how do you kind of
make sure that you're actually
articulating that you can solve the
problem are there certain
frameworks or tests that you run or
anything that you say like
i know that i'm hitting on the right
spot rather than just hey i just wrote
an email to a bunch of people i sent it
and you know cross my fingers and hope
it works
yeah i'll talk about this in the context
of maybe like a facebook ad
um just i think it covers more so if you
want more tactical stuff i think um
you know there's a book called
breakthrough advertising which is now
you can buy for 125 bucks or so
um i bought it for 600 because it's out
of print at the time highly recommended
it really taps into human psychology
and the whole skill of copywriting has
not changed we're all we all still have
the same needs
um there's another book called the 16
word sales letter written by this guy
who's a copywriter for um agora which is
they do over a billion year and their
primary like a financial newsletter so
that's kind of tactical on that side um
for me what i do is um from
breakthrough advertising there's this
framework that i use so it's
upside so it's up i got this from um
these digital marketer digital marketer
podcast and it's basically from the book
so
basically you're taking a prospect from
unaware to problem aware
to solution aware to aware of your
solution so that's the why
and then you give them a deal right so a
video ad can do that but also a long
form facebook ad can do that too right
and what i'm looking to do when i do
that is um
you know what can i do what kind of
story can i tell exactly
and also i'll run the copy through a
sentiment analysis tool as well you can
use grammarly it'll tell you if your
your
your content's positive or not but i use
the sentiment analysis tool as
long as it's positive um because
generally you want your content to be
positive
then um you know we're good to go but
for me
i'm you know i'm just looking to say
like you know one one
like here's how you do modern day seo
and then boom boom boom here's like a
tweet storm
um and i'll give a bunch of tactics
right like that's what's worked best for
me
um and yeah i think that's the framework
i use
you also have talked a bunch about um
kind of people who are building
companies being
vision driven uh i think a lot of people
say in a pitch deck or something like
hey here's our vision for the company
but it's not so much a measurable vision
um in the tweet you talked about
microsoft saying we want a computer on
everyone's desk right or
spacex saying we want to get to mars and
something that you can kind of
tangibly measure against talk a little
bit about how you've seen people do this
well
yeah so i think when it comes to um
you know for me vision mission values
like that stuff used to be like oh like
that's so intangible like what are you
supposed to do with that and then you
you realize
the the vision is what ultimately what
matters is the people right but if you
want to keep the people together at the
company
you got to have a great culture and how
do you have a great culture we need to
have a unifying
uh vision right and so um you know
whether it's you know we want to put a
pc on everyone's desk
or we want to organize the world's
information that's something that's
motivating and something
something that people can wake up for
every day right and i remember um
howard marks from from activision so
he's got an interesting story but he's
like
look you know we wanna his vision is um
we're gonna
we're gonna help all entrepreneurs right
and he's like well you say it's broad
but
like that's what a vision is like it's
not supposed to be attainable but it's
supposed to be motivating and inspiring
so i used to have like very specific
numbers like um
before i learned all this i was like oh
the goal is to make it a hundred million
dollar company like that's not
motivating at all
so now you know i got the book coming
out i'm like oh dude you know what's
easier
like my mission is to level up the world
because i just like learning and i like
teaching
and because i do that that's led to all
these other opportunities right
and it just feels right and so when you
tell your like
when people are trying to join your
company like what's the vision well the
vision is to level up the world like you
can wake up and say
let's do this let's do it right versus
like oh it's to to be a billion dollar
company right that's like not as
motivating
absolutely um you've talked a lot about
um
this idea that people get distracted
in today's digital internet based world
uh there's
notifications there's sounds there's
flashing lights
you know you go to a website and
literally it's covered with ads
like everything is distracting uh but
you don't necessarily think that that's
the worst thing in the world there's an
opportunity to turn that distraction
into a productive skill explain what you
mean by that
yeah so i think when okay so as an
example um one of the like i don't have
many notifications on my phone but
one notification i have on um or i had
on was twitter right so
let's say someone like uh let's say uh
james clear or naval ravicon day tweet
and one of the things you do if you want
to grow on twitter is you respond
immediately
as the first one right as you know um
and so that to me is a helpful
distraction because that's helping me
you know build relationships perhaps um
and
you know the other notifications i get
let's see what else do i get it's
so there's that one i don't have my my
message notifications on
um i'm trying to think what what else
it's kind of escaping my mind right now
maybe we can come back to this one maybe
it'll just hit me okay
the other thing that i think is really
interesting is you've been running
uh twitter ads and uh when i came on uh
and talked to you the last time uh it
was kind of this idea like
nobody's really running twitter ads so
like maybe there's a mispricing there
how have you thought about that
uh kind of experiment and what have you
learned yeah i'll just talk about miss
pricing in general i
think um so twitter i think is very
underpriced attention because um
it's we're running we're spending like a
hundred dollars a day we should probably
be spending more
but we're just promoting certain blog
posts and so there's um
there's a very big stock exchange that's
one of the
um my ad agency's clients and um they
saw
a twitter ad that i had out that was
mainly targeting sas people
and um the email thread read was like it
was like why aren't we getting this fire
right like we
we want this right and that led to a
whole you know upsell conversation
um and led to the contract getting
bigger and not only that um
you know we got a ton of qualified sas
leads from that
and so it just makes a lot of sense
because some of the smartest people in
the world are hanging out on twitter
right and so whether i want to target
e-commerce or sas or other like or even
like uh you got you
had andrew wilkinson on this podcast he
targets vcs on there to get them to sell
you know dead zombie companies to him
right so um
i think the attention is heavily
underpriced and he doesn't spend that
much either and you know talking to him
and so i think that's a great example
but i think
you know with upcoming book two i'm like
okay what's under price you know what
the gaming influencers out there that
have couple hundred thousands or
millions of subscribers
i'm like dude i'm talking to all these
agencies right now like the cpms or the
cost per thousand impressions
and to try this like i'm like man i
should just if it works
i'll do this all day because if you look
at the tim ferriss book
he really targeted mommy bloggers a lot
of bloggers in the early days and
i think it was underpriced attention got
them to help promote that's that's what
i think happened
um but same deal here right so i think
if you can
if you think you have a good um if
you're good at sniffing out the
underpriced attention go all in on it
right so
absolutely um you've got a book that's
coming out called leveling up
uh talk a little bit about why write a
book
you've got all these great skills in
terms of reaching people on digital
platforms
uh some people would say hey a book's
pretty antiquated what was the thought
process there
yeah so wow there's a lot in there so um
the the reason i decided to do the book
is not to try to make money and by the
way like i could have gotten
an advance from it we we went through
this hybrid publishing model where i
have control of the rights and yet it's
going to be
going through a publisher i can do all
the marketing stuff i want to do like
book funnels and things like that happy
to talk about it
um and i was like look i think this
message needs to get out there because
you know there's three billion gamers in
the world um and
you know me growing up i used i spent so
much of my time playing
uh you know poker first person shooter
games you know a lot of mmo rpgs
and i'm like look my parents used to
look down on me like my friends used to
look at me saying it's a waste of time
and all that but i'm like
the time i spent all those skills are
actually just like sports they're a
gateway into the real world
um yes you are like when you're playing
a game it is kind of a shadow world
but take those skills translate it into
the real world and
honestly every day right now pom like i
feel like i'm playing a game like
i can do podcasts i can work on this i
can work on that i'm just jumping around
it's just so fun
and so that's why i decided to do it
hopefully if you can you know change a
few people's lives that's great
but i think it's the message um that's
more important to me than anything so
hopefully you know we're able to spread
the message um and again it's not to try
to make money
um not to try to you know didn't make
any money off of it
out the gate and then what i would say
too is um
you know if you want to talk about
promotion happy to talk about it but
i do what is what is a book funnel
so a book funnel is and i'm sure you've
seen this um
there's a lot of people running facebook
ads right now um
or maybe even google ads to they'll be
like hey pomp like i'll give you my book
free but all you have to do is pay
shipping what happens when you do that
is you put your credit card information
in no the next page you know what
i got some other stuff to sell you and
usually the conversion rate on the next
page is around ten percent
and so if i if i have a book
maybe might say oh my god i'm you're
eric you're losing money because you're
you're just like
you're giving the book away for free and
you're shipping it and all that but my
next page might have
an offer that's maybe thirty dollars or
a hundred dollars or so let's say
it's a hundred dollars converts at ten
percent there's your ten dollars right
there
you're basically self you have a when
you have a book funnel
you have more control you can actually
make money on that initial campaign and
then you can sell whatever you want
um in the back end when they're on your
email list that's the entire play that's
what these all
a lot of these internet marketers have
been doing um and if you want to start a
book funnel
either software called click funnels and
they literally have a template that you
can use
to build a book funnel so that's why we
went hybrid because
after we make this initial push um we're
probably gonna switch and really use our
marketing prowess
if you guys are so good at doing this
which obviously you are
why even mess around with any of the
book publishers you know you didn't get
in advance
um and it sounds like you have a ton of
flexibility what was the advantage to
working with them
yeah so there's um there's this book i
really love called the coaching habit
and um you know
my publisher is called page two and they
i just wanted to work with them
and um you know the the guy that wrote
the coaching habit
michael he was like yeah they're a
pleasure to work with they know exactly
what to do so
they were basically telling me what i
needed to do like i got all this stuff
done with the book they did
they handled the cover like i have these
badges in the book it just looks good
right like the process was
iron tight um i cuz i just don't want to
deal with like you know all this other
stuff
so um the process was locked in and um
they
told like they have their sales team
working on it right now they're like and
so
for winter they're like um the book is
going to be
our lead book i was like what does that
mean and they're like oh it's going to
be the main thing we focus on
um so i was like okay that's exciting so
there's this element of
the book you know this pre-covert i was
like okay this book's gonna appear in
the airplane bookstores
oh not airplane bookstores the airport
bookstores
um they're like yeah we're gonna sell to
barnes noble and all that all that's
gone now
so but the problem is i signed a
contract already so that
additional benefit of you know their
sales team helping with all these
physical locations
has kind of diminished but that was one
of the major benefits in addition to the
process
got it and so what else are you guys
doing kind of under your own control for
somebody who's listening who wants to
launch a book you've got the book funnel
idea which is fantastic
anything else that you guys are doing
that you think will be very valuable
yeah in terms of promoting a book yes
yeah so
the things i honed in on so um we talked
about the gaming influencer so
you know we're using um we use a tool
called follower wonk which can
can search people's twitter bios and a
lot of these gaming people they put
their email
their emails in the bio and they always
use like a dot gg
um you know at the end of the email so
we found a bunch of emails through that
and then um just kind of sorted by a
number of followers and then we use
another tool called tensor social
to find a bunch of gaming influencers um
you can
you can basically search for the
industry and then sort by engagement
rates and then you can actually find
their emails as well and export it
um so there's that and then we
um we're going to be using facebook ads
and then you know driving them to a
contest as well
so for gamers we have a contest where
it's like you can win
a new alienware computer a new gaming
chair new headphones and all that
and you know um for the main entry it is
to
basically uh maybe subscribe to our
youtube channel or get on our email list
or whatever you can give like three
points here two points here whatever
and so hopefully that the contest tend
to work really well
but we're also giving away um you know
the first chapter of the book away for
free
and then the final thing i'll say is um
podcast tour that's the biggest thing
right so that's that's part of the
reason why i'm i'm getting on a bunch of
podcasts right now
that pushes books because naturally you
know people are listening to this
podcast for you
but also like whatever the the guest
tends to say um if they
align with that message then great so
absolutely
if people buy the book what are they
going to learn in it
yeah i i think i mean the book is
basically
it talks about it compares the world of
gaming
versus business right so there's an
anecdote about gaming and then there's a
business comparison and how it's
exactly the same thing and then there's
a quest like something to do at the end
right where you can kind of build up you
know those habits for yourself
essentially the entire book is about
creating the right habits and leveling
up from that perspective
because in life i mean there's um
there's a wealth ladder concept that um
you know another entrepreneur his name's
nathan barry he created it and so you
know i i would argue
that the first thing you want to do is
you want to build the right habits
obviously you want to learn the right
skills and then you maybe you start
working for someone right that's you
know what your parents want you to do
and eventually the next step is you know
you might freelance somewhere
and then the next step after that is you
might build an agency right or
you know rewinding a step you might uh
build a drop shipping business and then
you might build an e-commerce business
where you have the inventory
and then you can move on to the next
step right where you eventually you have
like a platform business
um you have a network effects business
um or you even have like a spacex or
something like that but the whole idea
here is
you're continuing leveling up to level
up um
and it's all it's all rooted within your
habits first because if you don't have
the good
if you don't have good habits like
you're not going to be able you don't
have the right foundation
to level up to where you want to go yeah
how much of kind of the leveling up and
and going from the platform business
strategy
is uh you're just practicing like you're
literally acquiring the skills and
getting better and better and you can go
bigger and bigger from that
versus something else is at play yeah no
i i think it's um
it's you're just you constantly one of
the things um so one of our core values
for
for the agency is um growth right you're
so you're constantly seeking
growth and you're constantly seeking how
to improve and then also improve you
know the world around you right and
ultimately at the end of the day you
know whatever's going on politically
like um
you know that's that's how you add value
to the world and that's how you become
successful
um and so i i think that's what it is i
mean you create your own luck that way i
think it's um
you know as long as you make sure that
you know you're constantly optimizing
yourself and
you're iterating um know what you can't
level i i just think there's no
like if you have the right habits and
you have you're hanging out with the
right people
there's no way in my mind that you can't
become you know the success that you
want to become right so i just think
you know everything i was told you know
growing up in asian family like um you
know your fate's kind of determined and
all that i'm just like
none of that makes sense so a lot of the
messaging the way you were programmed
growing up i'm trying to unwind that
programming
absolutely you are one of the best
marketers in the world
uh how would you say people who want to
get better at marketing
uh can go do that is it finding other
people are there specific
books courses like what would your
recommendations be
yeah i guess i'll just share kind of my
story around that um
so i was working a dead-end job coming
out of school so this is when the
financial crisis hit
um and i was doing data entry and um
my friend who was working american
apparel at the time now works at airbnb
she was like
you should check out this this digital
marketing thing got an internship
and what happened with the internship it
was a free internship and then what i
found out afterwards is hilarious
but they hired a cohort of 12 interns
and they had us writing all these
articles
right and by the same time they gave us
all these digital marketing courses so
what i did was
i'll come back from work every day and i
would basically come back at like you
know 3 or 4 p.m i'd come to work early
um and i'd study till 12 a.m right so i
go through all these courses and i just
go whatever i picked up on like oh seo i
just go deeper on and go to google
and anyway what happened was for that
that internship
they um were basically using us as
content writers for free
right and they had a bunch of content
created and they started ranking for all
this stuff so
um but anyway i kept going deeper i
went deeper on like seo for example and
i actually ended up going to this blog
called quick sprout which is
um at the time it was my uh podcast
co-host neil's it was his blog and
you know what i did was i would try to
email these people all the time because
i'd have follow-up questions right i
learned something so
i was not only learning i was asking
follow-up questions and eventually it
got to the point where
people like me or other people whether
it's me pestering them or whatever
um they're like dude let's just get on
the phone so we got on the phone and
eventually with neil um we ended up
meeting at a taco bell in orange county
down in
california and that's how we became
friends but that same
process that template where i was just
learning and then i was also
asking questions or i was learning and
trying to add value to people kind of
like
like how we talked about earlier that's
how i built my
network around marketing where i could
continue to ask questions because
the stuff you learn online maybe it's
like 90 to 95
of the stuff people are willing to share
the problem with marketing is if you
talk about it
everyone starts to do it and then your
tactic becomes um invalid or your
strategy
so you typically just like with business
and like these uh
business or marketing you want to hold
five to ten percent of the things and
not
share it um so ideally that's why you
build your network of
you know smart business people or smart
marketers absolutely
where can people go find the book yeah i
mean they can
um go to their favorite online retailer
just type in leveling up eric sue
um or i mean you can get a free chapter
of the book um
you know at levelingup.com awesome where
can people find you on the internet
yeah um there's me on instagram at
erico siu same thing with twitter at
eric osiu those are probably
the best two spots awesome before we
wrap up i ask everyone the same two
questions and then you'll get a chance
to ask me one
uh the first question is what is the
most important book you've ever read
and you can't say your own yeah uh
most important book i i thought about
this um
a while back but i would say the most
the one that comes to mind first right
now is the hard thing about hard things
just because
the entire book is about struggle and
that's basically what life is
so yeah that's a fantastic book uh ben
horowitz uh from andrews and horowitz
um highly recommend that one as well uh
second question is more fun
aliens are you a believer or a
non-believer believer for sure wasn't
there just something that just came out
about how there's like 300 million like
galaxies or something 300 million
planets supposedly exist
i always joke and say when i was in
middle school in high school there was
only nine
and we were in the big debate was this
pluto a planet or not
now we're at 300 million so i don't know
where how we went from nine to three
hundred million but uh that's where we
are
well how do we know anything that that's
my whole thing right i would say still
as human beings we're fairly primitive
right now like how do we know
you know so well we probably don't right
it's probably some
estimated guess of like oh we could see
you know x number of square miles here's
how many planets are in those square
miles so like
you know if you multiply that by the
number of square miles we think are out
there
like this is what it could be right some
math like that i'm sure
yep what question you got for me to wrap
up
uh i would say what do you what do you
think so you know winklevoss twins are
like it's gonna go to 500k
where do you think bitcoins going oh
like over a long period of time because
their whole thing was
the 500k uh over time right i don't
think they put like a time frame on it
uh i tend to think that they will look
uh
very very bearish with only a 500k
number on it over a long period of time
you know i'm talking 20 30 years i think
for sure we'll see
uh a million plus dollars uh bitcoin
um the big question is because i think
you'd get like about a million
if you got to 2x the gold market cap
right so like you know not unreasonable
uh over a really long period of time
um the number that i put out publicly
more short term is 100k by the end of
next year
we'll see right uh so far so good uh
right we're we're trending in the right
direction but uh as we know this thing
has a
has a mind of its own super volatile and
uh and we'll rip people's faces off in
both directions so uh
you know we'll just wait till uh the end
of december uh 2021 to see what uh what
happened
i love it awesome eric listen thank you
so much for doing this i think people
are really going to enjoy this
uh highly recommend the book highly
recommend them following you on social
media
and we'll have to do it again in the
future thanks for having me